my name is Nicola Revere I'm a kernel
developer here at Wolfram research I
work in the Mathematica algorithms in
R&D group and today I'm going to be
talking about dates and calendars I'm
going to try and give sort of a general
overview but then drill into a couple of
individual points to try and hopefully
give some some interesting details to
those of you who are familiar with the
date framework and also give enough of
an overview for those of you who are
still fairly new to the date and
calendar systems we have right now so
I'm basically going to start with what
comprises a general date and calendar
framework to begin with what are the
components of time that we're interested
in and then I'm going to dive into the
specifics of how we represent those in
the Wolfram language what the specific
parameters we have our and then drill
into some of the sub elements like a
string elements calendars time zones
holiday calendars etc and then I also
want to spend some time talking about
some future areas of development that
we're we're just starting to work on so
basically one of the the fundamental
points of dates is that they represent a
specific point in time there there are
some caveats to basically everything i'm
going to say here because it turns out
dates and calendars are kind of
complicated and you know we sometimes
have to argue about whether general
relativity or special relativity apply
to post it to specific applications but
in general and we're talking about a
date it's a fixed moment in time so
today is a fixed date the resolution
that we care about may change but there
isn't ever going to be another one of
today and one of the things that that
can often times be confusing is that
there are two sets of time units that
apply to dates a general time unit is
something that we consider a duration so
are our units framework applies to this
where we have fixed relationships
between units in the unit framework a a
month has a fixed value in terms of the
number of seconds that comprise it
whereas with in calendar units
oftentimes these relationships are
relative the length of a month varies in
different calendars another point I'd
like to talk about is epochs and the
Year Zero fundamentally there isn't a
universally agreed-upon beginning of
time we can argue that the Big Bang is
essentially the the origin of time as we
know it but if our calendar years I'll
start with 0 15 billion years ago we're
going to be working with really really
big numbers so at a certain point the
way we choose to represent the start
point of any timesystem is arbitrary and
we need to recognize that when we set up
things in terms of calculations time
zones are another important component of
dates and calendars they represent
generally geographic regions where we
have an agreed-upon standard of what the
current time is often times these
include daylight savings time and
generally they're regulated by local
groups it's not necessarily something
it's universally agreed upon which is
why we don't have daylight savings time
observe everywhere and some countries
don't can conform to our offsets from
gmt the last topic which I'll talk about
in more detail a little later on is time
systems also known as time standards
this is where things like leap seconds
come into play and they deal with the
way that we account for what the
specific time is right now and how we
deal with things like variations in the
Earth's rotation because a day is not
exactly 24 hours there are variations
and certain events can alter that and
they change historically ok so the
ten-second overview of the Wolfram
language is that we use a proleptic
Gregorian calendar it's epoch is at
midnight January first of the year one
on the Gregorian calendar we use a
24-hour leap second free clock and we do
not absorb or we do not observe your 0
all of this is very consistent with the
ISO 8601 standard for calendars which
I'll reference a few times the main
exception is that the ISO standard has a
year 0 we generally don't observe that
because historically we don't talk about
a year 0 in the Western calendar we go
from one bc or one BCE to one ad or c ii
the way that those standards are
observed basically varies depending on
country and particular implementation
with a bunch of different ways we
represent dates in the wolfram system
the primary one which hopefully you're
all familiar with now is date object
it's a rapper that contains information
that we haven't ever been able to store
and dates before it maintains
information like time zone and calendar
type which we traditionally haven't been
able to do anything other than infer one
of my classic representations is date
lists which are six element lists that
show year month day hour minute second
we have absolute times which are a real
value of a number of seconds since our
epoch date strings we have all kinds of
different representations there in more
recently we've added in Julian date
which is a rather than a number of
seconds since an epoch it's a number of
days since an epoch with generally a
real value that includes the number of
fractional days and that's from a
different origin point unix time is yet
another purely numeric representation of
time it's based on the number of seconds
that have happened since midnight
january first 1970 greenwich mean time
and then i've included side aerial time
here which is a slightly different
representation it relates to time in
terms of your your Astro metric position
or the relationship between the earth's
rotation and the Sun we have some
convenient constructors like now
yesterday today tomorrow that are quick
references and ways to create data
objects either to the specific moment or
to a general day we also have basic
operations that you may do on dates you
can add calendar units to a date you can
compare the the duration between two
dates you can generate a range we also
have date value which lets you extract
properties we can do timezone conversion
and calendar conversion so now we're
going to dive into hopefully something
that that's a little bit more
interesting and we'll get into some of
the specifics so date string has been
around since very early versions of
Mathematica in version 10.3 and 10.2
we've tried to add additional elements
in things like a DB see some of the iso
standards here that give us different
representations of time there's a whole
bunch of elements and included in in
being able to extract certain elements
we also have ways to format time
differently so the ISO standards
provide guidelines because every
different region has to have different
representations of how they show time we
have ambiguity of you know whether fifth
of 10 / 10 / 15 is 10 / 5 / 15 is
talking about may or october and so the
iso standard basically says you always
have a four-digit year followed by a
two-digit month followed by a two-digit
day and they also have standards that's
allow you to specify time as well their
additional standards for specifying
alternative representations so instead
of calendar year month and day you have
year week number within the year and day
number within the week or ordinal dates
which give just the year and the day of
year for date value we can extract a lot
of the same elements but it gives us
some benefit where we can specify
different output types so we can say you
know what hour is it right now and it's
actually returning an integer value for
us by default we can customize the
different values that are returned and
it's oftentimes useful so you can you
know you can set up a quick utility
function that takes a day or it takes a
date as an input and it can say okay I
don't need to call to expression I don't
need to do anything fancy and just get
the numeric value out and do a
comparison date format is an option we
have for date object which allows you to
specify the way in which the date is
type set by default we use our default
value for date string format which
includes the short version of the date
and time and then we also add in the the
timezone explicitly but you can specify
a custom formatting so you want to use
iso week dates the fundamental date
under the hood is the same it's just the
way in which we choose to present it is
different and that affects things like
date strings where you can say I want
the you know when you format it
explicitly will inherit that formatting
but you can also override it very easily
if you want it to be presented a
different form okay now we're getting
into interesting stuff so time zones if
any of you are familiar with working
with dates generally time zones tend to
be one of those things that people to
want to tear their hair out with because
daylight savings time is is something
that's observed throughout much of the
world and it's something that just is
insanely complicated for what it really
needs to be for most of mathematic is
history we've had time zones represented
as numeric offsets from gmt and so you
know when you initialize your your wool
from Colonel it will look at your
operating system or whatever system it's
running on and figure out how far you
are off from gmt when you generate times
those will be returned based on that
that timestamp and throughout the system
we have a time zone option that can be
used to specify the output time we don't
have a option anywhere that says what
the input time zone is because most of
the time dates are done relative to your
dollar sign time zone so if I type in a
date list into a function it's always
assumed that it's in the time zone my
system is in and one of the big benefits
of data objects is there actually
containers where we can say no this time
is in gmt and it can propagate
throughout the system without me
constantly having to modify what the
assume time zone is yeah and so for
example we can if we create a date
that's assumed to be in our current time
zone and we say we want the output time
zone to be our time zone it doesn't
change if we use block of our dollar
time zone we say our soon x into
something different now when we turn it
into time zone offset of minus 5 the the
relationship is now different because of
our assumptions about what the input x
on our data object is slightly different
and that the time zone option that goes
into it is both considered an input and
output time zone if you type in a time
zone or if you type in a date and you're
given explicit time zone we assume both
the input and the typesetting output you
want for it are the same you can always
change it through functions like
timezone convert there are a couple of
minor exceptions unix time and Julian
date are both by definition in GMT so
they do not take a timezone option you
can't specify that I want this
to come out in unix time in gmt minus
five because by definition of the
function it's not something that that
follows the standards now the most one
of at least for me one of the most
exciting things we've added in version
10.3 is support for non integer or
non-numeric time zones that being we can
actually finally account for daylight
savings time in the Wolfram language
after 25 years the way that we've done
this is we've plugged into a large
timezone database and one of the
complications of doing this historically
is that the the time at which time zones
change is not necessarily constant we're
constantly legislation is changing the
date on which daylight saving time
starts or ends historically they've also
changed so even though current local
time here is offset from gmt by six
hours or by five hours historically we
may have been offset by a different
amount and so there's a whole bunch of
relational information we need to know
about those time zones we've extended
this to include name time zone so i can
say based on standard naming conventions
that i'm in time zone america / chicago
as a convenience we also have if you
start typing time zone goes to we'll
have our autocomplete which isn't
running in this slideshow mode will give
you a list of auto completed time zone
so you don't have to remember them we
also have parsing for these so i can ask
wolframalpha i went mountain time i
don't know that it's america / denver
we've also extended our entity framework
to include time zone information so i
can give a location as the time zone so
when i say my time zone is in bangkok it
will look up the time zone that is
actually in bangkok right now and assign
that to the data object and then we also
have they automatically adjust for
daylight savings time so the typesetting
here we have is in central time or a
central standard time prior to daylight
saving time on set this year and
afterwards it's now indicating that it
is in central Daylight
we also if you want to explicitly look
up a time zone entity associated with a
location we have local timezone so I can
ask for the time zone in Tokyo you can
also through the entity framework get a
complete list of all 463 time zones we
keep information on and this we've also
added a new system variable which is
your dollar timezone entity which gives
you the local entity associated with
your computer's times an offset next
thing I want to talk about a little bit
as holiday calendars which in general
are a slight extension of the idea that
calendar time units are different than
then standard unit time units so the
idea of a holiday is a given day but you
can't convert a month into specific
holidays they're always relative they're
they're a type of day and their type of
occurrence and so we've done is create a
database of holidays for different
countries and also for different
exchanges and we can do things like say
I want all of the the holidays that
occur during the week with it between
two different periods I can compare that
to a different holiday calendars which
is the the Chinese national calendar I
can compare that with a different
exchange like is on New York Stock
Exchange one of the things that you can
also do is specify a custom holiday
calendar so in this case using a set of
three different pure functions I'm
saying any day on which the that we have
may ninth is considered a holiday so as
long as the month parameter is five and
the day parameter is nine it's
considered a holiday so I can generate a
holiday of different ranges across
different years our recent updates to
this have primarily been extending the
data so we've included additional
information for different countries we
now have a much longer list of available
holiday calendars we've also added
additional exchanges such as the tokyo
stock exchange for some of our financial
computations additionally we extended
the the day framework which is related
to the date framework
to some of our more general functions
previously if you want to compute
holidays you could only do them on days
without a time component and we
basically generalize that so we can
extend things more easily so I can ask
for I can say to add 250 business days
to today on different calendars and we
can see that there's a difference in the
number of holidays that happen between
the Chinese national calendar the the
United States calendar right another
aspect of dates that can be a little bit
complicated as calendars I said earlier
that we use a proleptic Gregorian
calendar that means we extend the
Gregorian calendar back prior to its
official adoption in the 1500s often
times there can be confusion about this
because of the the way in which the
Gregorian calendar was adopted they were
basically different time periods or we
switched from Julian to Gregorian it
caused a whole bunch of havoc in Great
Britain in the in the 1700s and people
write it in the streets because we
basically lost two weeks of time the
only real difference between the two
calendars is the way they account for
for leap years the Gregorian calendar is
more accurate to the the Earth's
rotation but in addition to those
calendars we've also taken two of the
more widely used calendars throughout
the world which are the Jewish and
Islamic calendars and so I can generate
date objects on those calendars for
today that include typesetting for the
month and day names and also you can do
conversion from a given date object in
this form so i can say i want to take
today and convert it to the jewish
calendar directly within a data object
and i get a date list form but because
it's wrapped in in data object we can
track the fact that this isn't a
gregorian calendar we're not talking
about some day really far in the future
it's it's the same day as today it's
just represented differently in the
language a couple of notes oftentimes
with calendars we get into fuzzy areas
where for example the islamic calendar
there for at least four major different
variants of it that all have to do with
the way
we observe lunar cycles the way we
represented in the Wolfram language is
the most widely adopted internationally
it's the lunar hijri calendar and
basically it's one of the tabular
calendars or more recent adaptations
they fall more in line with standard
computational systems we don't have
someone going outside and determining
when the new lunar cycles started which
is the case with some of these older
calendars or some of the calendars that
are used in different places which make
them really hard to use computationally
and so hopefully in the future some of
the tabular calendars will be more
standard but for the time being we try
and have the language be is accessible
to as many people as possible so we've
generalized it based on that information
for calendar operations the main
operation we end up doing is doing
calendar conversions so I can take a
given date and convert it to different
calendars we also support it as an
option in different functions if you're
not using a data object for example and
you just want to have a date range using
date list you can specify a calendar
type and if we compare this to the same
calendar being generated on a Gregorian
list we'd get different dates because of
the ways that the weeks operate within
the month the the length of an Islamic
calendar year is not the same length as
a Gregorian calendar year okay so I want
to get into any application of taking
some of this information actually trying
to apply it so I'm going to glaze over
some of the history here but
traditionally there's the the Mayan
calendar as we know it is generally
broken up into three different parts
generally when someone talks about the
Mayan calendar they're talking about the
Mayan Long Count calendar it's the only
calendar we can really relate to in
terms of a Western calendars because
it's the only one that has a finite
cycle both the hob and the tolkien
calendars are cyclical but they
basically don't keep track of where they
are within time once it finishes a cycle
it just starts over so we don't know how
many cycles have elapsed there there's
still some dispute about exactly when
the the Mayan calendar started but in
this example I'm going to be using the
most widely recognized epoch date which
is set by a good
Martinez Thompson correlation basically
one of the things that makes the mayan
calendar interesting compared to Western
calendars instead of year month day we
actually have five different parameters
we have keen which is analogous to a day
unal which is 20 different 20 days a
tune which is 18 unal a cartoon which is
20 tune and a baktun which is 20 cartoon
which basically ends up being a 1000 day
cycle and basically the you know when we
talk about the Mayan count you know in
2012 when every was talking about the
Mayan calendar events that was the
basically the mayan long count
calendar-- cycling through a new period
when the Mayans believed that every time
I go finished that basically the world
was destroyed and created again so there
are a bunch of different ways we can
represent the epoch what I've chosen is
to use a modified Julian date basically
to simplify the example a little bit but
basically we want a fixed point in time
where we know the relationship between
the Mayan calendar and another calendar
system so we're going to use the Julian
date because it already increments once
for every day so I'll choose a specific
date which is generally considered the
most widely accepted by scholars which
is basically the year 3144 bc on the
gregorian accounting for calendars and
the way that we do conversion because
these cycles are fixed we don't have to
worry about lead months or anything like
that is we basically just add our epoch
to the number of each of the different
parameters x their scalar factors and so
for a basic example date here we can say
that it's the the seventh Bach tune with
in the cycle 17 18 19 2 and we get a
fixed number this is the number of days
relative to our epoch what we can do
then to convert to a yet convert them to
a Gregorian date is basically use the
features we've already built into from
Julian date where if we
give it a Julian date it will convert it
to a calendar date for us so I can look
at that example input and figure out
when that would be on the calendar year
or on the gregorian calendar so it'd be
April thirtieth of the year one and I've
specified a time zone here just because
the by default from Julian date will
give me a date back in my current time
zone and I'm at this moment not really
concerned about it counting for for
daylight savings or anything else with
them relative to these conversions okay
so basically all we need to do is I've
set up this utility function here where
we basically are just multiplying by the
calendar units i can add an extra layer
in here and say that i want to take from
julian date of the input here and then
i'm using the date value function with a
date object specification to say i don't
actually care about what time of day it
is we're basically just looking for
calendar to calendar conversions here so
i can put in the arbitrary mayan long
count calendar day and i get back a
gregorian calendar date yay now most of
us don't have a lot of reference point
for mayan long count calendar days to
try throwing in here to actually check
it so we want to go the reverse
direction the basic operation is the
same again because this calendar is
cyclical we don't have to worry about
leap years or anything like that we
basically take that Julian date and then
we just subtract the epoch so we have a
fixed number we know relative to those
cycles and then we're just taking the
quotient and remainder by each of the
the unit factors here so we're figuring
out how many bak two Narracott Thun Thun
doing all and keen and then we can just
return a date list here I've done a
floor operation at the end basically
again to chop off anything related to
the time within the day just to simplify
the example but I can look at my epoch
day and make sure indeed if i take that
Julian date and I feed it in i get back
the epoch date within this calendar
system so 00 all the way down I can also
take a given date here so i can say on i
want to look at April first and turn
that into a Julian date I can feed that
Julian date in and then I get the
appropriate mayan long count
wonder if I want to convert from any
given date format and I don't want to
necessarily have to feed it into
julienne date I can basically make an
extra wrapper function here which says
it's accounting for time zone offset and
basically just calls Julian date or a
modified Julian date and then calls my
utility function so I can type in a date
string and it will turn it into the Long
Count calendar date I could give it an
absolute time I can check today and I
get the same result so because of the
way that we uniformly handle dates if I
can feed it into one of these utility
functions like Julian date it basically
just handles everything from there for
me and then I can do a sanity check just
to make sure I actually am
round-tripping dates if I turn a
Gregorian calendar date into long count
and then convert it back I'm getting
back the same date that I put in ok so
that's basically an overview of what we
already have in the system I'm running a
little low on time so I'll give
basically an overview of the three
things i think we still need in the
Wolfram language one I alluded to
earlier is handling of time systems one
of the complaints we occasionally here
is that the Wolfram language doesn't
have a good way for handling leap
seconds right now that's done
intentionally because there are a bunch
of different leap second standards
there's UTC 0 which is generally not
widely used anymore UT one or universal
time standard one is generally the best
standard but it is in current most
people use UTC which is an estimate of
you t0 there's TI a TD t there's a whole
bunch of different things going on and
we want to make sure we can address the
system as widely as possible because it
does matter for things like astronomical
calculations the way in which you
account for you know relativity when it
comes to averaging the different atomic
clock says they're spaced around the
globe there things like you know
earthquakes can change the rotation of
the of the globe there's a bunch of
different things going on there but it's
an active area that we're looking at
trying to develop another thing we'd
like to add right now that I alluded to
a little earlier is generic or recurring
dates we don't have a native language
representation to say februari first of
any given year we can we can say it for
a specific year but we can't say all
februari first so that's something we're
interested in pursuing and we've got
some ideas but it's something that we
definitely
appreciate feedback if it's if it's an
application area that people are
interested in and then the last example
is also time spans so being able to we
can explicitly generate a list of dates
but we don't have a great uniform way to
represent this event started on this
date and ended on this state and
happened all throughout there's also
ambiguity of it happens sometime between
this point and this point so there's a
through versus during ambiguity and
we're trying to take all those into
account so we can have a good system
that works for all application areas
unfortunately pretty low on time here
but I wanted to pitch Ghosh's giving a
talk right next door on time series
processing in a couple of seconds here
but that that's definitely an
application area I'd suggest and later
on today min is also giving a talk I've
included some links to some of the
things i discussed like the iso standard
also linked to the iono timezone
database if you're interested in finding
out more about time zones i've linked
knock'em dershowitz this book here as
well which is great if you want to get
into calendars and I've also included my
email address if you have any questions
or there's anything you feel like we're
not addressing in the time system yet
definitely feel free to drop me a line
so thanks everyone